she may be the darling of many
progressive Democrats but freshman
congresswoman Alexander Acacio Cortez is
taking enormous criticism from some in
her own party and her own state for her
role in Amazon's decision to cancel
plans for a huge investment in New York
here's correspondent Doug mackelway
Democrats are often called the party of
the big tent but critics say Amazon's
decision to bail on a new headquarters
in Queens New York has exposed the
party's other reputation as a circular
firing squad why in the world would you
celebrate driving 25,000 jobs at a Long
Island City I mean that is just
ridiculous Amazon said the average
salary for those 25,000 new employees
would have exceeded 150 thousand dollars
per year bringing in an estimated twenty
seven point five billion dollars in tax
revenues over the next 25 years a
windfall especially considering the
state only had to give up three billion
dollars in tax incentives to entice
Amazon but the increasing leftward
anti-business tilt of the party helped
poison the deal when Amazon executive
told NBC quote if you talk to Alexandria
Ocasio Cortez it's never Amazon
every day people in the community stood
up and they wanted to say poles found a
majority of New Yorkers supported the
deal despite Amazon's non-union policy
even in this union rich city and see
what basically we're left with now the
bombed-out cars in our neighborhood this
is not shangri-la over here we needed
this over here we needed this more
traditional Democratic politicians
supported the two Governor Andrew Cuomo
fumed quote a small group of politicians
put their own narrow political interests
above their community wanted to
negotiate a better deal we didn't want
to see those on the left those who are
anti-capitalist completely killed the
deal
it's the latest fissure in a party which
is smarting from the controversies of
late term abortion blackface and sexual
harassment in Virginia an embarrassing
rollout of what some Democrats say is
the overly ambitious green New Deal and
accusations of anti-semitism within its
caucus those controversies are all boxes
that President Trump may be checking for
later use when his reelection campaign
gears up Rath Doug thank you